اذا الرئيس اردوغان يظهر من هذه الشوربه
الشرفه عفوا في اسكودار
لالقاء كلمه امام مناصريه
وناخبيه يلوح لهم
بانتظار ان يلقي الكلمه الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سارى
اسطنبول كثيرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نحن عشاق اسطنبول
ونحن
بدانا مسيرتنا مع اسطنبول وها نحن نستمر
مع اسطنبول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
كسبت اليوم منطقه كسكلا جميله
بطراز اخر
ومنطقته
اسكتار جميله بنوع اخر واسطنبول جميله
بنوع اخر ايضا
ايها المناضلون ايها الاحباء انني احييكم
بكل محبه واحترام
[موسيقى]
ارادتي شعبنا
واختيار شعبنا ها نحن اتممنا الجوله
الثانيه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه انني
اتقدم بجزيل الشكر الى هذا الشعب النبيل
الذي
صندل برشلونه
من الاحتفال بعيد ديمقراطي بين عيدين
مباركين وانا
اشكر جميع المواطنين الذين حرصوا على
الذهاب الى صناديق الاقتراع
[تصفيق]
تسجيلاتهم
كل من وانا
اهنئ صندوق واشك واشكره جميع العاملين في
شكل المنظمه الحزبيه من المنظمه النسائيه
والمنظمه الشبابيه وغيرها واهنئ ايضا فريق
الحمله الانتخابيه
في امريكا واهنئ لسانه
جيش
واهنئ شبابنا
[تصفيق]
واهنئ كل من تبنى في قلبه
وبنى في قلبه قضيه حزب العداله والتنميه
وكذلك
اشكر كل من سارع
للتصويت في صناديق الاقتراع وذلك بنسبه
عاليه وكذلك
انني قد
اتحمل نعم وانا اشكر هذا الشعب الذي وكلني
هذه المهمه مهمه تحمل المسؤوليه تجاه
الشعب خلال الولايه القادمه الممتده لخمس
سنوات
وان شاء الله تعالى
[تصفيق]
ان شاء الله وان شاء الله
ساكون لائقا
بثقتكم كما كنت على ذلك
على مر 21 سنه ماذا قلتوه ان لقاءنا لن
ينتهي عند حد ما لقاؤنا ومحبتنا ستستمر
حتى الممات باي باي انظر ماذا يقولون
باي باي كمال الى اللقاء كما يحبكم قلنا
المقدسه لن تتعثر
وكلما يدعمنا
ويعلق علينا امالا لن
تخيب عمله
[تصفيق]
استاذ استاذ
ويمكن ان نضيف باي باي
ثلاثه
كمال
الحمد لله
انتم
انصتم الى ندائنا وان هذا الانتخاب وهذا
الاختيار اليوم هو تجسيد للمحبه القائمه
بيننا في
الانتخابات كما ان
[تصفيق]
انا الان
اقدم لكم حسابا وهذا الشخص المدعو كان
يدعي بانه خبير في الحساب
تعرفون كم عدد النواب في 2018
لحزب الشعب الجمهوري 146
والان من 2023 169
عدد النواب لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
ولكن كما لا يخفى عليكم
ان الاحزاب التي ليس لها
نصيب وتمثيل حتى بنسبه واحد بالمئه ماذا
فعل مكنهم من النواب وكم عددها هؤلاء
النواب اربعين يعني كم الان تراجع في
الواقع عدد النواب في البرلمان
لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
تسعه وعشرين ويبدو انه بسبب
نوابه الذين
فقدوه ربما حز الحزب نفسه سيسائل
ونحن
وسيحاسب ايضا هذا الرئيس ونحن نقول ان 85
مليون برمته
هو الفائز في هذه الانتخابات
انا سبق ان قلت شيئا اخر تذكروا
كنا نحن سنحقق
فوزا لن يخسر فيه احد
[تصفيق]
اذا اليوم
المنتصر تركيا
[تصفيق]
سنستمر في طريقنا دون التراجع عن اهدافنا
وتنميتنا وقد فتحنا بابه مئويه تركيا مع
بعضنا البعض اليوم
وجميعه اطياف الشعب من الشباب والمسنين
والنساء والعاملين وغير العاملين وقد
حققنا هذا الشوق مع بعضنا البعض
ونحن لم نخيب اعماله من كانوا
تتوجه الينا
انظرهم وقد رفعنا هذه الامنيات معا انظروا
انظروا هذا الميدان انظروا الى ذاك
الميدان كم هو رائع
[تصفيق]
يا اصدقائي
يسجل اليوم التاريخ
[تصفيق]
بكون من اهالي ومن اهالي اسكودار ومن
اهالي اسطنبول احمد الله حمدا كثيرا
لانه انعم علي بشعب مثلكم
وسننتصر ونحتفل سنحتفل معا امامنا عام
2024 تفهمون تفهمون ماذا اقصد
وفي عام 2004 وعشرين
هل انتم جاهزون لتحقيق الفوز في اسطنبول
وفي اصدار ايضا اذا علينا بذل جهود كبيره
دون التوقف
[موسيقى]
والان قلت
من عدد المتجمعين قيل لي المتجمعون حاليا
قد بلغ 55 الف
[تصفيق]
الانتخابات مره
والسيول تذهب والرمال باقيه الهدف هو عدم
حياه بلدنا من الاهداف المنشوده الاهم هو
ان يتمسك الشعب
بارادته وتوحده واعتقد اليوم قد تم اطلاقه
هذه الرساله المهمه وقد كشفت نتائج
الانتخابات مره اخرى لا احد يستطيع ان
يجرؤ على مكتسبات هذا البلد الان هناك
اتصالات من مختلف بلدان العالم قبل قليل
اتصل باخي رئيس اذربيجان الهام علياف
وكذلك رئيس اوزباكستان شوكت مرزايه او
اتصل بي
ليبيا وكذلك رئيس الوزراء الليبي
وكلهم
يتصلون بي
واحدا تلو الاخر ويقولون
نحن قادرون على المجيء حتى الان اذا ما
وجهتم ليه الدعوه بعد الاعلان
لانهم يريدون ان يحتفلوا معنا وفي الغرب
وفي وكذلك قطر اتصل
ويتقاسمون معا الفرح
وبالتالي
لا احد يمكن
ان يمده يد السوء الى الحريات
والديمقراطيه في بلدنا ولا احد يمكنه ان
يجرؤوا على تحقيق شعبنا
ولا احد يستطيع ان يوجه اصابع الاتهام الى
تركيا
ولا يمكن ان يعرقلنا احد من مسيرتنا ولا
احد
يستطيع وهو قادر على ان يمنعه شعبنا من
الوحده والتوحد والقوه وتمثيل تركيا جميعا
اخوتي الاعزاء الان علينا
ان نصيح بصوت عال
كي تسمع انقره وجميعه مناطق اسطنبول
هذا الشعب
الجمهوري هل هو مناصر
للمثليين وهل هذا
كذلك
حزب
الشعب الديمقراطي وحزب الجيد والاحزاب
الاخرى الصغيره كلهم مناصرين
للمثليين هل يمكن ان يتسرب هذا الانحراف
المثلي الى
حزب العداله والتنميه وهل يمكن ان يتسرب
ايضا الى الحركه القوميه وحلفاء
ايضا تحالف الجمهور ابدا كما قال يونس
امره ونحن في نجدد انفسنا في كل
الانتخابات العائله مقدسه عندنا ولا احد
يستطيع ان يتطاول على العائله العنف ضد
المراه محرم عندنا ولا احد يستطيع او ان
يجرؤ على ذلك ونحن
لن نتركه بسلام
خلال المرحله القادمه
سنحقق وعودنا ونحن
سنبقى متمسكين بتنفيذ وعودنا ايضا وبهذه
المشاعر والكلمات الان ساتوجه الى انقره
وهذه المره
سيكون خطاب
خطاب للشرفه في المجمع الرئاسيه ومن
المجمع الرئاسي
ساخاطب العالم
هل تسمحون لنا هل تسمحون لنا اذا
نقول بصوت عال حتى
تسمع تركيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبهذه
المناسبه ايضا اشكر
اخوتي المقيمين في المناطق المنكوبه
والمتضرره بالزلزال
وهؤلاء كلهم ذهبوا وصوتوا في الخيام وفي
المناطق المخصصه لهم ايضا
وان شاء الله خلال سنه واحده سافي بوعده
بتوفير المباني لهم نقول
انه من اجل علم واحد ودوله واحده
ومتى واحده السنه تحت ونتوحد
نقعل الثبات وسنظل اخوه وكلنا سنمثل تركيا
[تصفيق]
تركي تركي
[موسيقى]
هل انتم جاهزون
كلمات الاغنيه
لمن يسمع ومن لمن لا يسمع
ولمن يسال ولمن لا يسال اننا نحبه نحبه
نحبه
[موسيقى]
يا الله
يحب اسطنبول كثيرا
نحب اسطنبول نحب اسكودار كثيرا
دمتم بامان استودعكم الله
[تصفيق]